شدوا الاحزمه وتعالوا نطير على الولايات
المتحده وتحديدا ولايه منسوته الواقعه في
الغرب الاوسط من الولايات الامريكيه وندخل
مدينه من نابوليس وتحديدا مدينه ويزاته
هنلاقي المبنى الجميله اللي قدامنا ده
المبنى ده هو المقر الرئيسي لواحده من
اخطر الشركات على وجه الارض شركه وزير
الزراعه الامريكي الاسبق روبرت برجلاند
العنها انها بتمتلك افضل منظومه
استخباراتيه لتسويق المحاصيل مقارنه بافضل
جهاز استخبارات في العالم هو وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه المبنى
اللي قدامنا ده هو المقرر رئيسي لاكبر
شركه خاصه في الولايات المتحده واحده من
اكبر الشركات الخاصه في العالم وهي عملاقه
الاغذيه العالمي شركه كارل اكيد حضراتكم
مستغربين شويه ازاي يشارك كلها منظومه
استخبارات خاصه بشغلها ولكن اللي ما يعرفش
منكم فالشركات العملاقه زيها زي الدول كده
فيها اجهزه تنفيذيه مختلفه ومن ضمنها شبكه
استخبارات بتكون مسؤوله عن جمع المعلومات
من الاسواق المختلفه وعن الشركاء
والمنافسين والمستهلكين وعمليات البيع
والشراء وغيرهم والهدف الاساسي للمنظومه
دي انها تخلي الشركه تاخذ افضل قرارات
ممكنه تخليها تنجح وتزدهر وتحقق اعلى
ارباح وده موجود في كل الشركات الكبيره
فمبلنا بكار» احد اكبر المتحكمين في تجاره
الغذاء في العالم من اكثر من 100 سنه نظام
الاستخبارات التجاري بتاع كارل كفاءته
عاليه جدا جدا هو ببساطه بيتتبع المعلومات
المهمه وغير المتاحه لباقي المنافسين
وبينقلها بسرعه رهيبه بين مراكز صنع
القرار وبالتالي الشركه تقدر تعقد صفقات
ناجحه وتولد ارباح ضخمه شركه لها نفوسه
عالمي ضخم بيتجاوز الولايات المتحده
وبتمارس انشطتها بشكل مباشر من خلال اكثر
من 800 مكتب في 70 وبشكل غير مباشر في 125
دوله حول العالم يعني بنتكلم عن نصف دول
الكره الارضيه وعندها 160,000 موظف تقريبا
ده بيخليها تاثر حرفيا على مليارات البشر
وعلى اسعار ومدى توفر المنتجات الغذائيه
اللي حضراتكم بتشتروها وهنعرف كل ده
بالتفصيل بعد شويه يكفي انضرب لك مثل واحد
بيوضح حجم نفوز مجموعه كارجيل والساي
بتلاقيها موجوده وبتمارس نشاطها وبتحقق
ارادات بمليارات الدولارات حتى في وسط
الحروب والصراعات زي ما حضراتكم عارفين
الرئيس بوتن انضرب كورس في كلوب الاقتصاد
العالمي نهايه فبراير اللي فات لما بدا
غزوه اوكرانيا بعدها بدات معاناه اغلب
الشركات في العالم ومن ضمنهم شركات غربيه
كثيره
بعد فرض العقوبات الغربيه او تهرب من
اوكرانيا خوفا من القصف الروسي مين بقى
الشركه فضلت مكمله شغلها عادي في روسيا
وفي اوكرانيا وما تعرضتش لاي معاناه زي
باقي الشركات بالضبط شركه كارل مش بس كده
الشيء الغريب واللافت للنظر اكتر ان
الشركه حققت في فتره الحرب اللي اتحطت ال
10 شهور اللي فاتوا دول اكبر ارباح في
تاريخها كل الكلام ده يخلينا نسال شويه
اسئله مهمه جدا زي مثلا ايه حكايه مجموعه
كارجل دي وبتشتغل في ايه بالضبط ومين
بيمتلك التنين ده وبيديره واي حد مع ارباح
الشركه وهل جامعه ارباحها دي بطريقه مسيحه
وشرعيه ولا ارتكبت انتهاكات ويا ترى ايه
حجم تاثيرها على الاسواق العالميه خاصه
اسواق الغذاء والتاثير ده بينعكس علينا
احنا في دولنا العربيه ازاي دي عينه من
الاسئله المثيره جدا اللي هتجاوب عليها
وعلى غيرها النهارده بس قبل كده بافكركم
بالاشتراك في القناه لان اشتراككم مهمه
جدا وهو اللي بيساعدنا نطور من شغلنا ومن
المحتوى المخ والاقتصادي دائما ونحافظ على
مستويات بفكركم برده ان لحلقاتنا اللي
فاتت مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه فما تنسوش
تشاركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب وتعرفوهم على
القناه يلا بينا نشوف مجموعه كارجيل بتعمل
ايه في العالم انا اشرف ابراهيم المقبل
الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
غالبا هيكون عام 2023 في ركود اقتصادي وفي
الركود بيكون في فرص كثيره زي شراء اسهم
بخصومات بين 25 و70% في اسهم شركات زي
تيسلا وقابل وغيرهم وبيكون في فرص
استثماريه في الملزقات الامانه زي الذهب
والفضه اللي متوقع انهم يزيدوا انا شخصيا
لما اجي استثمر في شراء ذهب او اسهم بادور
على شركه وساطه مع العلم اولا لازم تكون
مرخصه ومراقبه من هيئات رقيه طبيعيه ثاني
حاجه اعرف اسحب فلوسي فيها بشكل فوري بدون
تدخل بشري ثالث حاجه تكون عملتها منخفضه
رابع حاجه تنفيذ التداول يتم بسرعه خصوصا
في سوق متقلب وفي فرص زي الاسواق الماليه
حلقه النهارده انا عايش شركه فيها كل
المميزات دي عندها خبره في الاسواق
الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز الاثنين
مليون دولار هو شركه ناس العالميه تقدر
تفتح حساب 10$ بس وتبدا التداول وفي اي
لحظه تقدر تسحب فلوسك بشكل فعوري ممكن
تجربه في وصف الفيديو تعليقات فيسبوك رغم
اننا بنتكلم عن شركه متخصصه بشكل رئيسي في
تسويق المحصله الزراعيه الا ان نشاط
مجموعه كورج الحقيقي اوسع من كده بكثير
هنلاقي الاخطبوط ده بيشتغل في تجاره
الاعلاف والبذور والاسماده ومكونات
المنتجات الغذائيه المصنعه وتجاره الاخشاب
وصناعه اللحوم والدواجن ومنتجاتهم
واستخراج الفحم والتجاره فيه وصناعه الصلب
وتجار تنفط والمعادن والعقارات والسكك
الحديديه والخدمات الماليه وخلينا نكتفي
الدول علشان وقت الحلقه كارجل هي شركه
عائليه يعني مملوكه لعائله كبيره هي اللي
بتتحكم فيها وهي عائله كارل وفي نفس الوقت
لازاله شركه خاصه يعني غير مدرجه في
البرصه وبالتالي فهي بتعتبر واحده من اكبر
واكبر الشركات العائليه الخاصه في
الولايات المتحده زي عملاق التصنيع
والتجاره مجموعه صناعاتكم للتمتلكها عائله
كوك وعملاق صناعه الحلويات شركه مارس اللي
بتمتلكها عائله مارس وغيرهم وبما اننا
بنتكلم عن كعملاقه في اول حاجه محتاجين
نعرفها عن الشركه دي هي قيمتها علشان نقدر
نقارن حجمها بباقي الشركات فيا ترى قيمه
شركه كارجل قد ايه بالضبط دلوقت القيمه
السوقيه لاي شركه عامه او مطروحه في
البورصه بنقدر نعرفه بسهوله خالص من خلال
ضرب سعر السهم في عدد الاسهم بتاعتها ولكن
الموضوع بالنسبه لشركه كارجيل مش سهل
لانها شركه خاصه زي ما قلنا تقييم الشركات
الخاصه ما بيكونش بسيط لان الشركات دي
بعكس الشركات العامه ما بتكونش مجبره على
الاصحاح عن بياناتها الماليه بشكل عالمي
وطبعا ما لهاش اسهم مدرجه في البورصه
وبالتالي ما بنقدرش نقيم حجمها بشكل دقيق
قوي ومع ذلك في بعض الاستراتيجيات او
الاساليب اللي بيلجا لها المستثمرين
لتقييم شركه خاصه صحيح في تونس لما جاءت
تقييم شركه كارجيل لجات لمقياس مضاعف
الارباح رعيته
لشركه عامه شبيهه بكرجل او شغاله في نفس
المجال وهي شركه دانيلز لاند للاغذيه
وتجاره السلع وده تكنيك او اسلوب شهير
لتقييم الشركات الخاصه من خلاله قدرت
القيمه السوقيه لشركه كارجيل لو كانت
مطروحه في البورصه بتسعين مليار دولار وده
بيخليها واحده من بين اكبر الشركات العامه
في امريكا وبالضبط في نفس حجم عملاقه
الخدمات الماليه ستروب في وقت تصوير
الحلقه الملكيه الخاصه او عدم الادراك في
البورصه خلوا شركه كارجل عندها هامش
ومنوره كبيره تستغله وتقدر تشتغل في
الضلمه على عكس الشركات العامه اللي بيبقى
في توقيت كبير على انشاطتها ويمكن ده السر
اللي خلى كارجيل بتقاوم كل جهود ادراجها
في البورصه على مدار اكثر من 100 سنه وتصر
على انها تفضل شركه خاصه وده بيفصل لنا
الارقام الصادمه اللي هاقولها لكم دلوقت
طبعا انتم عارفينه وحاسين سنه 2022 كانت
عامله ازاي اقتصاديه سنه ما كانش باين لها
ملامح هروب وصراعات ومعدلات تضخم مهوله
بتترمي في الشارع
اسعار كانت سنه صعبه جدا اقتصاديه على
العالم كله بس بالنسبه لكارجيل الوضع
مختلف فخذوا بقى المفاجاه دي كارجيل حققت
ايرادات لحد نهايه السنه الماليه اللي
بتخلص في اخر شهر مايو 2022 وصلت ل 165
مليار دولار وده بيخليها اكبر شركه خاصه
في الولايات المتحده خذ الكبيره بقى
الشركه حققت صافي ربح وصل ل 6.6 مليار
دولار هو اكبر ربح سنوي في تاريخ الشركه
اللي عمره 157 سنه الارادات والارباح
الضخمه دي خلت عائله كارجيل اللي بتسيطر
على 88% من ملكيه المجموعه ثامن اغنى
عائله في العالم بثروه تقدر
ب65.2 مليار دولار ده غير ان في ثلاثه من
اعضاء العائله
500 شخص في العالم ودول كمان مش كل
الملياردورات في الاسره الكريمه دي لان
العيله دي فيها 12 ملياردير في الوقت
الحالي وفقا لتقديرات مجله فرض طيب جميل
كل ده نيجي بقى لسؤال اساسي من اسئله
الحلقه مين عائله كارجل دي وقصتها هنرجع
مع بعض لبدايه الحدوته سنه 1865 بعد نهايه
الحرب الاهليه الامريكيه لما صديقنا
المواطن ويليام والاس كارجيل قرر يبدا
حياته المهنيه بتجارته الحبوب عن طريق
شراء مكان مجهز لتخزين الحبوب في مدينه
كونوفر بولايه ايوه في الوقت ده حكايه
تخزين الحبوب دي كانت جديده ومش منتشره
قوي والمزارعين الامريكيين كانوا بيعانوا
لتخزين ما حاصلهم ودخل لهم عين تحت رحمه
توافر وسائل النقل واسعار السوق المتقلبه
وده معناه انهم لو ما قدروش ينقلوا الحبوب
في الوقت المناسب فغالبا كميات كبيره منها
هتبوظ والباقي هيتباع في الاخر بقى اسعار
قليله وده فرصه لظهور بيزنس اصحاب المخازن
زي الاخ قاع الرجل ودول مجموعه من الناس
ما كانتش بتمارس دور فعل في سلسه الانتاج
الخاصه الحبوب لكنهم نجحوا في زرع نفسهم
كوسيط بين المزارعين وبين الاسواق اصحاب
المخازن كانوا بيشتروا الحبوب من
المزارعين وبيخزنوها ويستنوا يبيعوها في
الاوقات المناسبه وفي الاسواق المناسبه
ويستفيدوا من فرق الاسعار الضخم ومع توسع
بناء السكك الحديديه في الولايات المتحده
ناحيه الغرب توسع نشاط شركه كارجل معها
وبانت ثلاث محطات رئيسيه لتخزين الحبوب في
ولايه من صوتها وحدها وبعد 30 سنه من
النشاط ده وتحديدا سنه 1895 قرر ويليام
وليس انه يكبر عيلته ونشاطه التجاري في
الوقت نفسه عن طريقه ان يتجوز بنته وابنها
سليم مثلا اللي كانت شغاله برده في تخزين
الحبوب نظريه ذاتنا دي كبرت الشركه فعلا
لكنها عملت مشاكل كبيره مع وفاه الاب سنه
1909 مشاكل انتهت بسيطره جون المكمله على
اداره الشركه وعلى عكس ويليامرجل اللي كان
نمط قدرت تجاري شويه وبيميل للمغامره وخلى
الشركه تواجه صعوبات ماليه وديون في نهايه
حياته رغم الناجحات اللي حققها مكملا كان
معروف بطريقته المنظمه الصارمه وخطواته
المحسوبه والنهج ده خلاه ينجح في اداره
المشاكل الواجهه الشركه وانقاذها من
انهيار خصوصا خلال فتره الحرب العالميه
الاولى اللي كانت نقطه تحول لشركه لما
الحكومه الامريكيه يستعنت بها لاداره
لوجيسيات الغذاء في البلد بعد الحرب خارج
الكند- بتستعد لتسليم الاداره جونيور ابن
ماكملن وخريج جامعه هيل المرموقه وده كان
عنده خليط من الصفات الرياضيه والمال
الشديد للمغامره وفي نفس الوقت متمسك بنمط
الاداره الصارم بحكمته في الجيش تحت اداره
جونيور شركه كارجيل واجهه تحديات انا
نفسيه كانت الاكبر في مسيرتها المهنيه
خاصه مع توسع بعض ختان تجاره الحبوب
الدوليين
زي شركه بانجل الهولنديه وقتها ولو درايفر
الفرنسيه
في امريكا واللي ساعتها كانوا بيرسخوا
اقدامهم سنه وراء الثانيه في البلد متوسط
في سوق الحبوب الامريكي الضخم جدا مع تولي
مكمل ان جونيور رئاسه الشرق خاصه في
الاربع سنين اللي قبل الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وخلعها هنا كارجل برئاسه مكملين
علشان تواجه المنافسه الشرسه دي وتصمد
قررت بسرعه تدخل بعض الافكار الجديده
والثوريه في تجاره الحبوب ومن اهم الافكار
او الاستراتيجيات اللي قررت تشتغل بها
فكره عبقريه سمتها باسم الحزام الابدي او
انجلش ويا ريت تسيبه اللي في ايدكم
وتركزوا معي قوي في اللي جاي ده كرجل
وقتها قررت تشبه سلسله انتاج وتصنيعه
وتجاره واستهلاك الحبوب بحزام طويل من كذا
نقطه بيمر بعرض الاراده الامريكيه من
الغرب وده معناه ان الشركه محتاجه متقدم
يتحكم في كامل السلسله دي ويحقق الارباح
بكل نقطه منها السلسله دي بتبدا من الحقول
والمزارعين في ولايات الغرب الاوسط زي
ايوه ومن سوسه وسكونسن وده كوته وبتمر
بشبكات التخزين اللي بتمكن الشركه من
احتقار شراء الحبوب من المزارعين وسائل
النقل اللي بتتحكم فيها كارجل برده وصولا
لانقاط التوزيع والمعالجه اللي بتجري فيها
عمليات طحن الحبوب او تجفيفها زي الشيعه
وانتهاء بمراكز الاستهلاك الكبيره زي
النور على الساحل الشرقي وكمان محطات
التصدير في المدن الساحليه اللي بتتنقل
الحبوب عن طريقها للاسواق العالميه زي ما
قلنا فكره الحزام الرهيبه دي كانت قائمه
على تحقيق ارباح من كل مرحله من مراحل
الصناعه كلها بدل الاقتصار على شراء
الحبوب وتخزينها واعادها يعني من الاخر
كده كرجل هتبيع البذور للفلاحين وهتكسب
منها وهتشتري منهم الحبوب بعد حصادها
وحتحفظها في مخازنها لحد ما تبيعها وتكسب
يعني وهتبيع معدات الطحن والمعالجه وهتكسب
ثالث وهتبيع السمسم والملح والمحسنات
للمطاعم وهتكسب رابع وهتكسب كمان من النقل
ومن التسطير وهكذا طبعا الاستراتيجيه دي
كانت ثوريه جدا في وقتها لكن الثوره
الحقيقيه ما كانتش في ده وانما كانت في
نظام اتصالات واستخبارات السوق المتطور
جدا اللي عمليات الشركه واللي وزير
الزراعه الامريكي قال عنه انه اكثر كفاءه
في مجال عمله من السي اي اي زي ما قلنا في
اول الحلقه شبكه الاستخبارات دي كانت مهمه
جدا في الوقت اللي تم فيه قبول شركه
كارجيل كعضو في مجلس شيكاغو للتجاره سنه
1935 لان ده معناه انها دخلت لعبه تداول
العقود الاجله
تلعب ببساطه هي اتفاق لبيع او شراء كميه
محدده من سلعه بسعر محدد في تاريخ محدد في
المستقبل وهنا نتيجه اهميه شبكه استخبارات
كارل لان العقود الاج سلسله تحقيق الارباح
منها بيعتمد على القدره على التنبؤ
بالاسعار سواء ارتفاعها او انخفاضها في
المستقبل بالبلدي كده احنا بنتكلم عن
بيزنس قائم في جوهره على التنبؤ والاتصال
والمعلومات كل ما كان عندك معلومات دقيقه
قوي وقدرت تنقلها بسرعه كل ما كسبت فلوس
اكثر وتفوقت على منافسين اللي ما عندهمش
المعلومات اللي عندك خذوا بالكم اننا
بنتكلم عن عصر ما كانش في الانترنت وسائل
الاتصال متطوره خالص زي وقتنا ده اللطيف
بقى ان شبكه الاستخبارات دي واللي شركه
كارجل بتفتخر بها على موقعها الالكتروني
لحد النهارده مش هي اللي كونت قاعدتها
الاساسيه بنفسها امال جابتها منين يا اشرف
بكل بساطه اشتريتها عن طريق شركه منافسه
لها ركزوا بقى في القصه الجايه دي عشان
مهمه جدا لسنه 1923
استحوذت شركه على شركه مع منافسه لها في
مجال الحبوب في ولايه اسمها ساعتينور اند
بورماك شركه تيلي روبورنينج كان عندها
النظام تلغراف متطور جدا وقتها اسمه كلمنت
كارتس لتايب سيستم النظام ده كان ثوره
تقنيه بمعايير العصر ده لانه هتحل كارجل
نقل الرسائل بشكل فوري بين افرع الشركه
المختلفه بسرعه وبدقه وبتكلفه منخفضه
والاهم لسريه تامه النظام ده كان هو اساس
البنيه التحتيه لشبكه الاستخبارات اللي
خارج الاساسيتها في سوق الحبوب واللي كانت
بتدار ببساطه بالشكل التالي افرع الشركه
المختلفه في بوسطه شيكاغو مونتريال وغيرها
كانت بتشتغل بالاضافه لوظيفتها الاساسيه
كم مراكز لجمع اي معلومات ممكن تاثر في
سوق الحبوب وتقوم على طول تنقل المعلومات
اللي بتوصل لها اول باول غرفه العمليات
الرئيسيه لكرجل في مقرها الرئيسي
الغرفه بتحلل المعلومات دي وبتشوف تاثيرها
المحتمل على الاسعار في الولايات والمدن
الامريكيه المختلفه نعم على التحليلات دي
بتقوم كارجيل تاخذ قرارات التداول والبيع
والشراء في بورصه شكاوي يمكن ده يفسر بشكل
جزئي لشركه كارجيل قدره تحقق استفاده
وارباح مهوله من كل الازمات اللي ضربت
الاقصاد الامريكي وعلى راسها الكساد
الكبير من سنه 1929 لبدايه ال 40 اللي
تسبب في انهيار اسعار السلع والحبوب وازمه
قصعه الغبار اللي كانت عباره عن جفاف حاد
فضل ست سنين من سنه 1930 لعل 1936 وتسبب
في ارتفاع اسعار الحبوب بشكل كبيررجل تحقق
ما كسب مهوله فيها اوقات الازمات دي
لاسباب كثير اهمها شبكه الاستخبارات دي
لكن طبعا كان في ممارسه غير نزيحه لان
الشركه لما تنبات بارتفاع اسعار المحاصيل
قبلها خاصه الذره قامت سحابتها من الاسواق
وخزانتها لحد ما يرتفع سعرها وانطردت من
مجلس شيكاغو للتجاره سنه 19 38 بعد
اتهامها من كلا من هيئه تبادل السلع اللي
هي حاليا لجنه تداول السلع الاجله ومن
مجلس شيكاغو بمحاوله السيطره على سوق
الذره الامريكي الضخ في اول محاوله حكوميه
جاده للسيطره على الشركه لكن زي ما هو
متوقع المحاوله دي فشلت بسبب ضغوط لوبيات
الشركه على المسؤوليه وزاره الزراعه
الامريكيه قررت تسيب سوء الحبوب علشان
ينظم نفسه
[موسيقى]
في اواخر الثلاثينات قامت الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
انه جيتار حمايه للشركه ضد تقلب اسعار
الغذاء الخام عن طريق الاستثمار في
المنتجات المصنعه يعني بدل ما تاجر بس في
الذره الخام مثلا نتيجه في الذره
وشراب الدره على الفركوس واي حاجه ممكن
تطلع من المحصول الدوره الثانيه
وحتى الشراء وتسويق العقارات التوسع ده
حصل عن طريق سلسله من الاندماجات
والاستحوازات الكبيره اللي عملتها الشركه
في القطاعات دي والنتيجه ان كارجيل تحولت
لكيان عملاق مترمل اطراف وبيلتهم شركات
تانيه جواها في يوليو اللي فات مثلا
كارجيل وشركه كونتيننتال جرين اتم صفقه
وقيمه 4.5 مليار دولار لشراء شركه مزارع
ساندرسون ودي احد عمالقه صناعه الدجاج
والنتيجه ان كرجل كده ثلاث اكبر شركه
امريكيه للدواجن الاستحواز ده حصل بعد
معركه كبيره مع اجهزه مكافحه الاحتكار
الامريكيه وحصل رغم وجود تحقيق ساره من
البيت الابيض بخصوص عمليات الاندماج
والاستحواذ في قطاعات الدواجن واللحوم
تحديدا لانه لما يبقى السوق في يد مجموعه
محدوده من الشركات الكبيره ده بيرفع السعر
دائما على المستحليلك موضوع رفع الاسعار
والتلاعب والاحتكار ده نقطه مهمه جدا في
قصه قعر رجل وهو السبب الرئيسي اللي فينا
نتكلم عن الشركات دي لانها بتاثر عليك
وانت قاعد في قلب بيتك وسط اسرتك حتى لو
عمرك ما سمعت عنها او استهلكت منتجاتها
بشكل مباشر لان اسواق السلع والحبوب هي
اسواق عالميه زي ما كلنا عارفين فلما
الشركات المحتكره لتجاره الحبوب وسلسله
انتاجها بالكامل تعلي السعر بطبيعه الحال
الدول المستورده هتدفع اكثر وبالتالي
المنتج النهائي من الارز والمقوليات عموما
واللحوم وخلافه هيوصلك بسعر اعلى بكثير من
اسعاره الطبيعيه حتى في الاوقات العاديه
بعيدا عن فترات التضخم ومشاكل التوريد
والحروب وخلافه اصحاب الشركات والمليارد
زيك شركه كارجيل بيرموا دائما اسباب
التضخم في اسعار الغذاء على حاجات زي
مشاكل سلاسل توريد بسبب انتشره
او تاثر الانتاج بسبب الحروب زي الحرب بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا لكنهم بيفشلوا غالبا
يجاوبون كناس بسيطه
عن ليه في علاقه طرديه بنت ارتفاع اسعار
الغذاء من الناحيه وزياده حجم ثروتهم من
ناحيه ثانيه ده يزيد دايزيد في شهر مايو
اللي فات 2022 منظمه اوكسفام الدوليه
اصدرت تقرير كان في شويه مفاجات صادمه زي
مثلا ان العالم ظهر في 62 ملياردير جديد
في مجال الصناعات الغذائيه خلال فتره وباء
كرونه ومنها ان الاثرياء القدام في مجال
الزراعه والصناعات الغذائيه رفعوا اجمالي
ثروهم بنسبه 42% في السنتين اللي فاتوا
ودافئ نفس الوقت الاسعار المواد الغذائيه
العالميه وصلت في اعلى مستوى ليها في ال
10 سنين اللي فاتوا بسبب الوباء والحرب
الروسيه الاخرانيه التناق ده بين التضخم
الشديد في اسعار الغذاء والثروات اللي
بيجمعها اباطره الصناعه بدات تلفت
الانتباه اكثر مؤخره ومن ضمن المنتبهين
لها حاليا اداره الرئيس الامريكي
اللي بتقول انه جزء كبير من التضخم الحالي
خاصه في اسعار الغذاء يمكن تصنيفه تحت ما
يعرف بتضخم الجشع او جريد ان فلاش ده
معناه ببساطه انه في تجار وشركات بيستغلوا
اوقات الاضطراب اللي الاسعار بترتفع فيها
علشان يرفعوها اكتر بشكل مبالغ فيه وزودوا
ارباحهم الكلام ده بيفسر ازاي انت كمستهلك
في اي دوله عربيه ممكن تشتري القمح والرز
واللحوم وغيرها باسعار اعلى بسبب
الممارسات التجاريه اللي بتمارسها شركات
زي كارجل واخواتها من العمالقه والحيتان
على بعد الاف الاميال منه لكن برده تاثير
الشركات دي علينا بيتخطى قصه الاسعار على
اهميتها وخلينا احكي لكم قصص سريعه من
العراق العزيز تقعد وضح لكم ده في سنه
1971 صدرت كارل بعد ارتفاعا مع النظام
العراقي وقتها
95,000 طن من القمح والشعير المعالجين
بماده 200 للزئبق على الرغم من ان النوع
ده من المعالجه ضد الفطريات
منع تماما في امريكا والغرب الخطارته
وعلشان الشركه تخلى مسئوليتها لونت الشحنه
باللون الاحمر او الوردي وكتب التحذير
انها غير مخصصه للاستهلاك البشري ولا
الحيوان لكن ممكن تستخدموها يا جماعه في
الزراعه بس وفقا للبروتوكولات المعمول بها
والمشكله ان الشحنه دي لما وصلت العراق
والحكومه وزعتها في الاسواق بعض المزارعين
اكلوا من الحبوب دي واكلوها لعصارهم وده
ادى لوفات 459 شخص حسب الاحصاءات الرسميه
لكن المرجح ان العدد الحقيقي الوفيات هو
10 اضعاف تحت وده خلى الحادثه دي تصنفط
اكبر واقعه تسمم بالزئبق لحد دلوقت بقى
الواقعه دي اشتهرت في العراق باسم واقعه
الموتور الوردي والروايه الغربيه حواليها
بتميل لتحميل مسؤليتها للنظام العراقي
اللي تجاهل التوجيهات اللي بتمنع اكل
الحبوب او على الاقل اثر في دوره في
التوعيه ده والكلام ده يمكن صحيح من ناحيه
انه من ناحيه ثانيه بيتجاهل تماما دور
كارجل وامريكا نفسها وبيبرعهم من مسئوليه
وده مش صحيح بدايه كده ماده مثال الزئبق
كانت اتحذر استخدامها في الوقت ده في
امريكا ومعظم دول اوروبا بعد حالات تسمم
كثير لكن امريكا كانت وقتها بتسمح بتصدير
الماده للخارج بضغوط من شركات الكيماويات
واهمها شركه دوبوند اللي كانت من اهم
منتجه زئبق عالميه ثانيا الروايه الغربيه
اللي بتشيل الليله لان النظام العراقي
بتتجاهل حقيقه الوضع الغذائي في العراق
الفتره دي الوضع كان هش جدا بعد جفاف
الاسنان ونتيجه ده كان شائع من الفلاحين
بيستهلكوا فقد الحبوب المخصصه للزراعه
وبياكلوها ده غير ان شحنه الحبوب دي وصلت
في وقت متاخر من الموسم الزراعي فكان في
فرصه كبيره جدا انها تتاكل مباشره الحاجه
الاخيره المهمه ان تحضيرات اللي كانت
مكتوبه على الشحنات دي كانت مكتوبه باللغه
الانجليزيه والاسبانيه لانها كانت جايه من
امريكا والمكسيك وطبعا الفلاحين العراقيين
ما كانوش بيقراوا انجليزي ولا اسبانيا
الخلاصه ان اهلنا البسطاء كانوا بيمروا
بازمه غذائيه فجات لهم شحنه حبوب غربيه
لونها احمر مكتوب عليها كلام بلغات هم مش
فاهمينها فقرروا ببساطه يغسلوها ويطحنوها
وياكلوها لانهم في اشد الاحتياج لها طبعا
سجل كارجل مليان قصص الضحكات بالشكل ده
واحتكار ورفع اسعار وتلاعب بالاسواق وهكذا
ده كان سبب ان هنا للواكس مان عضو مجلس
النواب الامريكي السابق والرئيس وقتها
لمنظمه حمايه البيئه المسامات
يوصف الشركه بانها اسوا شركه على وجه
الارض واقسم من قال انه في شركات كثير جدا
ممكن تتنافس على اللقب ده لكن سجل كارجل
تحديدا يخليها تاخذ اللقب بلا منافس
بدايتها من الاشخاص اللي برده او ماتوا
بسبب تناول لحوم الشركه الملوثه والاطفال
اللي اشتغلوا في ظروف قاسيه في مزارع
الكاكاو اللي بتبيعه كارجل لصناعه
الشيكولاته والبشر اللي بيشربوا مياه
ملوثه في ولايات الغرب الاوسط الامريكيه
بسبب مصانع الشركه والناس اللي نزحوا بسبب
ازاله الغابات في الامازون افريقيا علشان
الشركه تبني مصانعها واخيرا المستهلكين
العاديين اللي بيدفعوا اكتر مقابل اكلهم
بسبب الممارسات الاحتكاريه للشركه وغيرها
من الحكايات اللي ممكن تلاقوها بالتفصيل
الممل في تقرير منظمه مايتي ايرث في
الواقع لو حبينا نحكي بالتفصيل عن
المخالفات البيئيه والتجاريه وانتهاكات
حقوق العماله والاطفال اللي خارج المتهمه
بارتكبها من قبل المنظمات المستقله فاحنا
محتاجين حلقه كامله لكن خلينا نكتب كلامنا
بحصائيه واحده هنبص على مؤشر الانتهاكات
فيوليشن اتريكر اللي بتذكره مؤسسه
فارسن تتبع قضايا الانتهاكات والم باسات
سيئه للشركات بيقول لنا انه من سنه 2000
لحد سنه 2022 تم تسجيل 199 مخالفه وانتهاك
للقواعد مرستها شركه كارديل داخل امريكا
لوحدها وفي امثله ثانيه في البرازيل
وافريقيا في مزارع الكاكاو اللي بتمتلكها
الشركه مثلا لكن هنكتفي بالاشارات السريعه
دي علشان وقت حضراتكم الانتهاكات دي تنوعت
ما بين الاعتداءات البيئيه وكسر قواعد
التسعير والمنافسات العادله وانتهاكات بحق
بعض العماله في رواتبهم وساعات عملهم
بالاضافه للمخلفات الماليه ومخالفات قواعد
السلامه ودفعت الشركه نتيجه لده وغيره
حوالي 190 مليون دولار من الغرامات
والتعويضات هو مبلغ لا هي كان يذكر
بالنسبه لارباح الشركه اللي بالمليارات
لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامك كالعاده في
النهايه عندي سؤالين لحضراتكم نقدر نعمل
ايه ضد الممارسات غير السليمه للشركات دي
ويا ترى تعرفها امثله ثانيه مش شركات ممكن
تكون بتكسب ملي على حسابنا من غير ما نعرف
قولوا لنا ايه هي وازاي بتعمل ده ممكن
نسلط الضوء على بعضها في حلقات ثانيه قريب
للي عايز يشتري اسهم او دهب ما تنسوش
تشوفوا شركه اكسيس هتلاقوا رابط تحت
الفيديو تابع ردودكم كلها في التعليقات ما
تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه زي ما اتفقنا
وياريت لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير
للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكم لاصحابكم وحبايبكم
عننا سواء عرب او اجانب يمكن يستفيد
وتعرفوهم على القناه
[موسيقى]